willkommen in einem nagelstudio ich weiß
nicht ob es eine gute idee ist aber ich
glaube 2020 ist das jahr des klopapier
und deswegen probleme mit klopapier
fingernägel aus ich habe auch gesehen
ein neuer trend ist so kristall steine
auf den nägeln also wie so ein
rosenquarz oder wie diese anderen
kristall steine und das wollte ich erst
mal ausprobieren aber dann dachte ich
mir ich bin noch nicht durch einem
klopapier und dieses klopapier hat ein
wunderschönes muster und zwar hat es
blaue federn drauf was mir jetzt
eigentlich schon tierisch auf den sack
geht ist dass das licht immer dunkler
wird und wir schon 19 uhr 19 uhr zwei
haben aber so gehe ich bin es gewohnt
stundenlang vor der kamera an meinen
nägeln herumzufummeln deswegen lass uns
nicht lang schnacken kopf nacken und
loslegen meine fingernägel müssen zuerst
auf jeden fall kürzer gemacht werden
wir brauchen natürlich auch ein schönes
vorher nachher
oh ja ich frage mich gerade ob ich
einfach so machen kann
es ist nämlich einen nagel knipser kombi
mal kommt von kenia durch ammar richtig
gut tut mir so leid an alle nagelstudio
mitarbeiter nagel designerinnen bitte
kommt weg also nageldesigner brauchen
ungefähr eine stunde ich versuche heute
dieses zeitlimit zu erreichen ich habe
ich keinen bock wieder hier vier stunden
zu setzen es ist schon mal passiert als
sechs stunden sitze ich hier mache mir
meine fingernägel man wird ja auch mal
gefragt welche form man haben möchte
ich möchte eine gerade form behalten und
nicht wieder dieses runde machen ich
finde es runde sieht man auch an wie
kaká so sieht mein erster nagel
abgeschliffen haus und das mache ich
jetzt erstmal mit allen bevor wir
loslegen können sind jetzt abgeschlossen
und gerade das ist schon ganz neuesten
handys geflügel die lange habe ich jetzt
dafür gebraucht eine halbe stunde
ich meine ich weiß ja das dauert länger
als name studio aber trotzdem es dauert
so unglaublich lange wenn man sich
selber macht
[Musik]
wir müssen sauber so alles satt machen
dann brauchen wir natürlich privat
primer
[Musik]
der brenta hhg wir brauchen eine base so
sieht unser grund ihr gel aus es ist ein
durchsichtiges gel und das mal wir jetzt
auf unsere finger okay also einfach
drauf das gute ist dass ich mir heute
nicht diese blöden tipps drauf machen
muss diese verlängerung bei diese
verlängerung darauf brauchen wir noch so
drei jahre extra weltlicher gar nicht
mal so schlecht drauf vor der land
verstecken und hand rein machen und
hoffen lasse nlwkn in einem nagelstudio
das blöde ist und deswegen dauert zeit
doppelt so lang man kann in der zeit
seine zweite hand nicht machen weil man
ja keine hand frei hatte das gefühl dass
ich mittlerweile gut mit meiner linken
hand arbeiten kann
habt ihr übrigens das video gesehen was
ich über koreanische asiatische serien
auf einer kriegs gemacht habe das habe
ich auf meinem zweiten kanal hochgeladen
der kanal heißt wann am pc und da kommt
halt alles so hin was ich so am pc macht
beziehungsweise auch wenn ich zb über
koreanische serien redet so zweiter hand
ist mein spiel schon ein bisschen warm
[Musik]
da carlo video mache mir die fingernägel
was ich auch die fingernägel macht
klopapier
das ist eine gute idee
es wird gut werden muss weitermachen
meine nägel arbeiten
du bist so hat sich liebt dich tiefen du
bist so alt wie ich liebe dich tschüss
so funktioniert unsere kommunikation auf
jeden fall sind die fingernägel jetzt
fertig und sie haben so eine
schutzschicht die schweiz schicht
entsteht wenn der nagel in der lampe ist
und dass aushärtet so ich hoffe jetzt
dass ich das einfach so draufkleben kann
das papier aus dem fingernagel wegen der
schmutzschicht also wir haben zwei
designs einmal so ein sehr ruhiges
genoptix ich weiß nicht ob man das auf
irgend einer kamera sehen kann und dann
haben wir einmal das design mit den
federn
das wird einfach servieren technik auf
meinem fingernagel so dann nehme ich das
papier eigentlich nicht rücken hab ich
brauche das ohne musste das muster kann
man nicht so gut erkennen dass wir
nichts vielleicht können wir selber was
draus machen in mir steigt so eine ganz
kleine angst auf dass das papier in der
lampe verbrennt und feuer fängt weiß die
chance ist wahrscheinlich sehr gering
aber sie ist da ja das ist ein schönes
muster ok und dann klebe ich jetzt drauf
drücken
dann muss doch nur abschneiden ich
glaube dass ich mich gerade hier
hochgradig konzentriert klopapier in
meinen fingernagel zu kleben aber ich
hätte auch nicht gedacht dass das bds
konzept dieses jahr abgesagt wird also
getan so liwingen wo also alle irgendwie
sieht es noch aus
nur theoretisch muss da jetzt eine
schicht drauf mache ich da jetzt auch
top coop der regelungs gehe ja um eine
schutzschicht keeper lars g
mal gucken was jetzt passiert
[Musik]
ich glaube eine schicht tür ist zu wenig
man sieht nicht wirklich passt zum glück
brennt meinen daumen nicht ab und fängt
feuer
das ist jetzt halt wirklich nicht sogar
überlege gerade ob man in kletzke papier
mehrlagig lassen sollte das war jetzt
nicht die beste idee was ist wenn wir
einfach sagt lassen wir hier so ein
bisschen klopapier vielleicht müssen sie
über glas gehen konnte
[Musik]
fragt mich nicht was ich hier gerade
mache ich weiß ein bisschen selber nicht
vielleicht finde ich auch gerade den
trend 2020 fertig bin einfach meiner
zeit voraus leute es ist so blöd es ist
schon wieder gut
doch das ist was was das könnte sich
durchsetzen
bis hinten ein paar sekunden später
erkennt das ist so stupid weil ich ja
wir versuchen für papier design auf
meine finger zu malen wie würde denn
klopapier design sein dass wenn ein zug
über die fingernägel müssten soweit sein
ach so müssten diese punkte haben und
diese federn visum klopapier halt wird
sie mein körper die finger gesehen
[Musik]
super stupid ist wie sieht denn
klopapier aus klopapier hat so punkte
und muster in babyblau rosa habe ich
dann irgendeine farbe nude papstes
zahlen judt make-up ja dann hätte man so
[Musik]
unser fehler dass sie gar nicht aus
ich möchte mir geile fingernägel machen
ich bin dem klopapier wisst ihr was
heute wir machen uns jetzt geile
fingernägel das ist sie eine reise und
wir machen einfach richtig geilen regel
scheiße auf klopapier fingernägel was
habe ich denn hier so da diese kleine
sticker mit eichhörnchen mit einhörnern
kennen die reds vor dieses kendras leute
möchte einfach verschiedene shades of
pink machen hab heutigen idee also ich
habe mich entschieden in diesen schönen
frühlingshaften pink ton also probieren
mal hier
der ton ist hübsch wie meine physische
bei animal crossing
[Musik]
so und jetzt immer so also ich dachte
was ist wenn ich jetzt in diese farbe
rein tun und das so durchziehen dann
müsste es doch so ein cooler effekt
geben
nein jetzt habe ich nicht farben
gemischt
versuchen sie zu sein
kriegt das auch nach den anderen hin den
anderen sieht cool aus
woraus ein cooles design jetzt jetzt
komme ich langsam denkt dass sie gar
nicht mal so schlecht aus
wer hier gar nicht mal so schlecht aus
kennt ihr das ja etwas macht indem nicht
wisst ob jetzt liebt oder hasst meldet
hey dad ich muss mir etwas überlegen was
könnte ich für ein nageldesign machen
leute ich mach mir die crystal nails ich
habe am anfang des videos über crystal
nails gesprochen
ich möchte christin elß ja warum habe
ich so lange drauf gewartet natürlich
möchte ich crystal nails kriegt das hin
wie es denn wir machen richtig wir
machen jetzt richtig esoterische nägel
wie september christel september bond
der lucky silicone september gestern ist
safi jeder sagt aber etwas anderes
christel pfau wirkung der love is ich
habe leider kein blau deswegen fällt der
raus kamelien houston saphir ob aldi
sind ali amiga hässlich ich habe mich
jetzt für den rosenquarz entschieden wir
machen rosenquarz fingernägel so richtig
schöne in stahe so großen quartz
fingernägel ich gar nicht so kompliziert
wir beginnen mit unserer rosa farbe das
sieht auf jeden fall aus wie so ein
christel ein rosenquarz
und macht sogar noch den nagel stabil
heißt es heißt das heißt es wird heiß es
wird heiß es geht es geht es geht es
geht alles was ihr auf eurer lenkt nach
macht müsst ihr auch eure rechten machen
auch wenn das zur bahnstrecke zu können
[Musik]
charlie charlie
ich hasse es dass wir beim training
machen mich durch die haare gehen kann
okay jetzt beginnt natürlich der
schwierige teil und zwar wie bekommen
wir diese weiße maserung auf unsere
fingernägel dass es am ende so aussieht
als ob es ein kristall wäre und nicht
einfach so hässlich drauf gemalt strich
habe mir da was ganz fantastisches
überlegt jetzt nehmen wir unser frank
white und machen wir mit der spitze
buchbar sind einmal so ein streifen
einzel-rennen komische ja eigentlich wie
dynamo effect nur das ist nicht mal also
noch sieht es ganz schön kreuz und quer
und nicht ordentlich aus aber das ändert
sich
stimmt ich versuche jetzt gerade so wie
wenn man die grenzen machen also die
rechte haben sie einen definitiven
besser aus
da kommen besser wird es nicht so wie
das gerade aus ist aber ja noch der
anfang
man soll den tag nicht vor dem abend
loben und andere kundin später komme das
ist gar nicht mal so schlecht da aus auf
jeden fall anfahren
so jetzt brauchen wir eigentlich damit
dieses hero sepang zeug nehmen das
gleiche mit dem weiß man kriegt ja auch
so was sagt ihr zu diesem
zwischenergebnis entwickelt die cool
sind auf jeden fall zeit für man kann
darin weise streiten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
kann ich beides nicht
doch mal ganz ehrlich so jetzt noch eine
schicht von dem rosa drauf aber auch
wieder nur eine ganz dünne schicht wir
wollen das weiß ja immer noch durchgehen
können den hallenbädern ganze nun bei
yahoo.de daumen sie können wir so
schlecht aus wie wichtig abkaufen
jetzt tue ich auch so mit dem pinsel
discos reihen zieht es nicht mehr über
alles wenn ihr seht wie mein name jetzt
aussieht damit ihr ausrasten vorfreude
sieht so schön aus also ich finde es gar
nicht mal so schlecht aus so schöne
rosenquarz fingernägel kreuth hin dass
sie seien so cool mir gefällt das
ergebnis richtig gut ich zeige euch das
ergebnis jetzt mal vom nahen und wünsche
euch jetzt immer einen wunderschönen
abend gute nacht und wir sehen uns beim
nächsten mal wieder eure mal wayne war
es dann